tras 15 días de guerra en ucrania y una
polémica interna creciente por no haber
recibido ni haber abierto las puertas
para refugiados ucranianos como el resto
de europa finalmente el gobierno
británico ha decidido flexibilizar las
reglas para que los ucranianos puedan
obtener la visa para venir al reino
unido- desde este martes 15 de marzo
quienes tengan pasaporte o un documento
de identidad pueden iniciar el trámite
para la visa de hecho viajar al reino
unido- terminar el proceso de ese
documento de la visa aquí en este país y
solamente los casos más complejos
tendrán que ir a un centro de visas en
alguna ciudad europea además de que no
tiene una política de puertas abiertas
para los refugiados ucranianos también
el gobierno ha estado bajo polémica
constante porque para obtener una visa y
un proceso burocrático muy lento lo que
ha hecho que hasta este momento se hayan
otorgado un poco menos de 1000 visas de
23.000 aplicaciones sin embargo para que
un ucraniano en este puede venir aquí al
reino unido tiene que tener un familiar
que respalde esa aplicación de la visa
lo que hace crecer esa crisis
humanitaria ha generado polémica y en el
parlamento se ha pedido por ejemplo que
las visas no sean un requisito para en
medio de esta situación para que un
ciudadano ucraniano y su familia puedan
llegar como refugiados aquí al reino
unido